jojo was geht hier vor max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video leider
nicht ganz alleine noch vollkommen
alleine sind in eine ferienwohnung
unsere vermieter haben gesagt dass ihr
bitte keinen besuch mitbringen sollen
geschweige denn laut sein sollten auf
jeden fall war ich heute in einem
spielwarengeschäft ich habe einfach das
hier gefunden leute es ist ein wc
basketballs z ihr seht schon wohin das
sollte alles geht
14 basketball und ja wir haben es zwar
nicht auf dem pc spielen sondern an
diesem bilderrahmen hierauf hängt dieser
benutzt ein fenster blöder haben auf
gerade wenn wir das geld das ganze
aufhängt und wir sagen wir packen es mal
aus das hier ist der chor das suchen wir
drei bälle in feuerrot ist ich will
sagen wir machen uns sechs würfe jeweils
wenn ihr und der verlierer muss dem
gewinner ein eis ausgeben dass das thema
so und sich ist es was ein schild war es
gar ein stück zu dicht ist wenn hier
also ich habe es hier gar angebrachten
gemacht musste einfach so was macht
drei würfe dass es schwer ist es richtig
schwer okay gesagt wir gehen erst mal
einfach verliert und wer fängt an sich
erste ausschnitte schere und ist
ziemlich unaufgeräumt übrigens senden
zuerst mal wieder dran
das ist christ da kommt dann aber ab und
zu rein okay leute
wir werden wirklich dankbar allerdings
habe sein
luca ist ein ersten drei würfe ist mir
nicht dann mit meinen ersten drei okay
wenn ein junger mann nämlich nicht nicht
versucht
aber komm schon
was jetzt vorhersage hochachtung film
hast doch nicht leiden heute ist das
ultra komisch dieses video gerade wir
treffen einfach nicht alles ist kein
spinner
als es komplett chaos von der band max
ist ein aggressives gerade alles ist
komplett chaos und ist jetzt mein
letzter chance aufzuholen
welchen trick shop machte das ist ein
trick
okay ich bin macht erstmal richtig nur
von hinten zieht auch von marie wie dann
wieder etwas hat ist schon alle drei weg
für eine häufige komme ich gerne bin hab
ich amüsiert wenn ich jetzt raffles
unentschieden junge vom wiener wir haben
vorher vorne geworfen
als 50 wie ich darauf reagieren
knapp bestanden haben später als wenn du
das gemacht was vorher war ja jetzt
einen tag später aber luca bekommt ist
ein eis
ja okay gut welches eis wird es gibt
also ein mittleres vanille zimt bitte
heute spricht okay leute das war's schon
mal im video macht's gut und müssen dann
nächsten mal tschüss